كما تدور الحرب هنا بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكرانيه تدور حرب اخرى بين زاعمي
البلدين بوتين وزيلانسكي حرب في الفضاء
الرقميه في ميزان الانتصار والخساره بعد
سنه من الحرب لم تحسم لاي من الطرفين لكن
في الفضاء الالكتروني يبدو بان المعادله
مختلفه تماما الرئيس زيلانسكي يمتطي صاروخ
الاعلام الرقمي الحديث مغردا خرج سرب
الصحافه التقليديه التي اعتادها سيد
الكرملين في هذه الصوره مثلا مشهد يختصر
فكره في الدعايه الاعلاميه مقابل اخرى
للرئيس الروسي نرى كيف يجلس بعيدا وبعيدا
جدا عن جنرالته على طاوله الاجتماع تباعد
يعكس مدى رسميه فلاديمير بوتين في التعامل
مع حاشيته وهنا زيلنسكي لم يكتفي سلاحي
العمر والدراما فحسب بل سرق الاضواء
بعفويته وقربه من الناس سيما عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
مساء الخير جميعا الرئيس هنا مدير مكتب
الرئيس هنا رئيس الوزراء هنا نحن باقون
هنا للدفاع عن اوكرانيا واسترجاع سيادتها
المجد للمدافعين عن بلادنا المجد
لاوكرانيا
وفي دائره الخطر زيلانسكي كان حاضرا
ومطمئنا فبعد اعلان حاله الطوارئ مع بدايه
الحرب والحديث عن قرب سقوط اكياف طمانه
زيلانسكي مواطنه بانه باقي معهم منذ اليوم
الاول لاندلاع الحرب على طريقه اسهل في
طبعا والثقه تحركاته خطوه بخطوه على منصه
التواصل الاجتماعي ولم يغب عن جنوده
المنتشرين على جبهات القتال معتمدا اطلاله
موحده القميص الزيتي ومرددا شعاره والدائم
النصر لاوكرانيا
القوات الروسيه هاجمنا العدو بخمسين الف
جندي مدججين بدبابات من طراز في 72 كما تم
القبض على خمسه من المعتدين